c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
c'est pas une vanne tumeur sert alors
c'est mieux le plus gros nez il fait son
nez il fait je vous le dis si ces terres
que le 59 centimètres de l'eau alors
j'ai un truc pour mesurer ici
ouais parce que je pense que j'aurais pu
faire podium quand je les vois si
j'avais vérifié mais tu pars pas battu
d'avancé tant d je regarde un troisième
place il ya combien troisième le
problème ce n'est pas tout les chiffres
n'étaient pas en bavière le cas non mais
est le gars le gars il ya quand même un
zen comme ça lui il va jusque là me
dites pas que j'ai gagnés sont blague
ah non non non et non pas croire droite
l'autre il a tous hâte puisque tout ça
puisque les deux vous vous faites un nez
à nez ce n'est pas faire refaire son nez
logan même et vous avez un tout petit et
en fait par rapport aux autres donc
jamais vous avez un nez à peine à trois
et demi franchement quand même bah ouais
mais bon quand même quoi il en est à
trois ans et demi ça franchement votre
n'est parfait je les ai vus de près les
beaucoup mieux c'est vrai mais ils sont
trois et demi c'est pas possible
jardin là parce qu'il y avait le doigt
il y avait le truc avant away mais oui
dans la fente away
[Musique]